beginning of my talk my waters already
gone there we go okay before I get too
deep into the slides I mean I'm I do
have some slides I don't want to talk
through but really I want to get into
some code and so I want to make sure
that we we spend time looking at some
code in in Visual Studio and I've just
created a little front end with angular
to call the restful services that are in
there and and they're really pretty
small so let me just maybe take a look
briefly at the application that we're
just going to take a look at here so
it's a little budget app as with most
developing projects I was thinking I was
going to make it a lot more robust than
it is but you know a time time was
against me and then the reality is is I
don't really want to focus on the front
end I mean contrary to what this screen
shows I do actually care about user
interface this is not exactly pretty but
but in any case I just have three basic
tables that I'm working against users
the users table categories and then of
course the budget or expenses this is
something that I've kind of toyed around
with a little bit just since I travel a
lot I kind of need to keep track of my
expenses and so in the past I've just
created a little database to store some
of that and this is a really kind of
trim down version of how that might look
just to track that and I'm not looking
at a income this is really strictly just
expenses so it could go it could go a
lot deeper than this in any case so with
the with the categories we could add a
category if we wanted to let's just look
at what the categories our food housing
transportation miscellaneous got to have
a slush fund
for whatever I want all right and I'll
add that too to my category and then of
course I've got users and none of those
are me and then and the home screen
that's just expenses and we'll take a
look at you know some of the some of the
things that we're gonna talk about and
is the you know how do we deal with
things like like paging and and so on
that doesn't seem like when you first
think about rest what that should be a
big concern and things but but it's
something we actually have to think
about as you look at restful services
and we'll talk about some of those
things and let's just get back to this
okay
so all of the code that we're gonna have
here I uploaded to github so if you're
if you want oh this will be available I
guess through through the NDC website as
well and of course you can see the link
there but you can download slides as
well as all the source code with this as
well just uses a sequel server database
on the back end for those that just got
four out of Cosmos I'm sorry it's not
it's not a JSON style database but
that's alright okay so what are we gonna
cover well we're gonna talk about rest
what is rest so just we have a basic
understanding I think we need to set
kind of a ground groundwork because
really the building of the restful
service once you understand is it's
really quite easy in web api so we'll
cover what is rest we'll take a look at
asp.net core web api we'll talk about
you know some of the things you need to
set up just to configure it again it's
gotten really easy so it's not that hard
to configure but we'll take a look at
that and then then we'll take a look at
swagger what is the role of swagger when
we're dealing with with restful services
and why might we use it rest and the
idea of rest does not new I mean that
this whole idea of communicating
distributed processing even before soap
and a SMX web services it's it's been
around much longer than that you got
we have decom before that I remember
building websites in classic SP where we
communicated with ups through XML with
get and post methods only so it's not
that this idea of communicating with a
server with a distributed and
business-to-business or not so much
business-to-consumer
it's been around for a long time we had
dotnet remoting that came out with
dotnet of course as well so had either a
SMX Web Services or dotnet remoting if
we wanted to do things internally and
then the limitations of soap or the ASM
X Web Services kind of gave way to WCF
then which really is I guess it's a
combination of a SMX and dotnet remoting
because you could you could really
choose to do both of those with within
WCF so in fact rest has been around for
a long time so why did I list it as one
of these last things because that I rest
was was actually available before WCF
but it kind of became popular a lot more
popular around that same time and the
first restful services that we could
build in in dotnet were in WCF so that
was if you really wanted to truly take
advantage of all the restful verbs and
actions we had we had to do that in WCS
like the asp.net webforms and a snx
didn't didn't allow for that we really
really had get and post methods at that
point and of course now there's graph QL
and there's gonna be a talk on graph QL
right in this room right after me which
that's a pretty exciting new new
opportunity of things things that are to
come and a way to program your your
distributed applications so all of those
are still available well WCF really is
like I said from WCF rest and graph QL
all those are really available to you so
how do we choose between between those
let's just compare those just real
briefly obviously we're going to focus
on rest in this session but I do want to
take
so WCF or soap a SMX web services really
their primary the primary thought there
was we want to distribute our business
logic we want to move it somewhere else
and so so as you look at old soap web
soap services or WCF services that's
really how they're architected the idea
is we're moving business logic over to
to a different layer so we make these we
call these endpoints with web methods
we'll take a look at some of the ideas
I'm because because it was so flexible
and removing the business logic in order
to really make best use of these types
of services we had to have heavy
documentation you had to really
understand what are the services what
are they trying to do so it's so it's a
very tightly coupled type of scenario
even though we're distributing our
processing the the front-end or a client
was was pretty tightly coupled to our
back-end in fact if you're using if
you're still using WCF services you can
you can have basically connected
services well similar to - oh my mind
just went blank
WebSockets there we go
we have open communications and things
and you leave a session open on the
server and and and you're communicating
back and forth so so you have to it's
very tightly coupled you really have to
understand what's going on on the server
very good for for full-stack developers
where you really have to understand the
entire process front to back the
endpoints as I mentioned have many
methods inside of them for for example
because the there's so much business
logic there you might return different
structures your the way your data looks
when it comes back or what goes in can
can very very drastically from from one
call to the next and so really as I
mentioned oh this is wasn't want to take
a look at that's really we consider that
kind of our business layer what about
rest rest is really a lot more resource
driven
and we'll take a look at why in just a
moment but but it's really based on the
resources that are that are there
there's really if you understand rest
there's not a whole lot of documentation
that's required because you understand
the the structure they understand how
rests works so the documentation goes
down quite a bit each end point is very
well-defined as well so it has few
actions in fact the actions that it does
have are are pretty well-defined as well
and really I'm probably look at that as
much more of a repository layer than
than a business layer we don't do a lot
of business logic on on the rest
endpoints
what about graph QL that came about and
you know it does graph QL really mean
the death of rest so graph QL similar to
rest is really focused on resources not
only the resources but one of the
limitations of rest is a resource within
rest doesn't really know much about its
resources so so we'll see is you have to
make a lot of you have to make a lot of
calls to get all the data that you want
and a specific client
whereas with graph QL the idea is you're
not just fork is focused on the resource
but its relationships and as the name
implies it's a querying language you can
actually define what data you want just
like in a sequel database when I do a
query I can join multiple tables I can
specify individual columns that I want
so with graph QL you can actually define
within your query what your data
structure should look like when it comes
back so there are some some pretty
strong benefits there as well it's much
more of a semantic model if you've ever
done any kind of business intelligence
or built built kind of a back-end and
data model like a semantic model that
analysts need to use the the concept is
very much the same you have to build the
structure on the back end and really
have a well-defined
model that can be easily queried on the
front end so there's some some heavy
lifting on the back end to make that
happen
and similar to rest again it has a few
actions and also it's think about it
more of a repository layer it just
responds to what we do it's a it stores
the data it knows how to get the data
and we can update insert the data and so
on the business logic doesn't reside
there the business logic communicates
with it and then determines how to how
to go there so a couple other things
server side versus client side
development and so I just wanted to as I
was preparing for this I kind of thought
well what what makes these three
different the server in WCF is very
flexible you have your business logic
you can you can make it do whatever you
want and therefore it requires all that
documentation because the clients have
to really understand how to use that so
the client therefore is rigid for for a
client for a web developer or a mobile
Android iOS developer to be able to to
get any changes they have to come to the
API team or the server developer and
request changes and and so they're there
it's very rigid and there's the
bottleneck there with rest the server is
quite rigid its well-defined as we
talked about as far as how how the rest
of the server should work and the client
is actually also quite rigid which if
you haven't experienced that we'll we'll
take a look at that as well because this
restful architecture really defines what
the server can and can't do that means
the client has to adhere to those same
type of principles graph QL in graph QL
the server again is quite rigid there's
some heavy lifting ridges may be the
wrong term there but but there's some
heavy lifting just to build the model
that I was talking about and making sure
that's available and and the really all
the work is done there and that is
because we want the client to be
extremely flexible because so the client
can say hey well this is the data that I
want and and then they can do
with the data how whatever they wanted
and then send the data back and the
server developers have to determine how
am I gonna deal with that data and how
how am I gonna process that and make
sure that we still have data integrity
at the end of the day as well
so there's there's trade-offs between
all of them so the question then again
which do I choose well it depends
there's there's not one that's the right
answer
that really they're that they all have
their place and where your development
goes so let's just take a look at some
of the ideas in this simple simple
application that was talking about with
WCF if I wanted to go with this data if
I want to get for example like a summary
of data on one of my pages I would come
in and I could get the budget item I
could get a user name and pair it up
with with all the expenses that that
user has incurred and maybe summarize
expenses for each category for that user
and I can return it all in one time so
because of that because of the flexible
nature of wucf I could have one endpoint
and one method that would do that so
usually it would probably be called
something like get users and budget by
category or something like that so the
more you start developing this and as
you can see this is just three tables so
as you start developing this the
endpoint names or the method names start
to look more like paragraphs than they
do like a quick action with rest on the
other hand we're really focused on the
resource and not the relationships so
with the relationships what the
trade-off there is I can just have a
verb I can just say get me all the users
but then for each of the users I then
have to go I have to make another call
to say get me all their all the expenses
and then I have to get all the
categories as well and then the client
can determine how to deal with that of
course we can filter it so we don't have
to get all the users in the database and
you know deal with the millions of
expense records just so I can display
ten records on my screen in graph QL
once again there it's it's related it's
an object relationship and we can define
okay I want the users and I only want
their first name and last name and I
want to see if I can build a rapport so
I can say I just I can specify which
fields I want just first name last name
I just want the category name or I guess
something to go all the way through the
relationship I want the the amount of
the budget items and the category name
I'd still have to do some aggregation on
my site potentially but in any case it
gives me some more capability of
determining what date I want and not
getting too much data back so what does
rest actually solve well as I mentioned
it's a well-defined architectural
standard the ideas were separating the
business domain or the business logic
from the server-side resources we have
very well-defined set of verbs and
actions limited set and it focuses on
the resource not the business logic or
the relationships so let's take a look
at some of these what some of these WCF
or soap methods might look like I
already mentioned some get all users I
might have one service that has this get
user by ID get user and budget by user
ID get user and budget own typos get
user and budget by category ID insert
user update user delete user so on and
so on this is by no means I'm sure I'm
sure you've all seen like api's that
just have dozens or maybe even hundreds
of methods that just that just get so
convoluted and and you need a dictionary
just to know what's going on you know
what what each of these methods are
doing
conversely rest has just a set of verbs
so we have get and get that's not an
accident because get usually what you'll
see if you haven't seen it already we we
have at least usually to get methods one
to get a list of all methods one that
gets an individual item we have a post
this is post input
this is one I don't know why but people
seem to have a lot of there's some
confusion around which one is an insert
and which one is an update post is the
insert and put is put is the update the
idea here is that a post obviously
you're inserting record and with put
we're replacing the entire record so if
we're going to stick strictly to what
wrestle services say I'm just looking
I'm looking the resource up by ID and
whatever I have I'm just going to
replace it so so it's not really
focusing on I'm replacing individual
items or individual portions of it I'm
updating the entire record because that
was so because that was so common and
some of these objects are rather large
we need to have an idea of being able to
replace just or update just a portion of
it and that's where I hope patch comes
in patch is probably not that often used
but and it was added later to to the
rest documentation but but patch is like
put except for it does give you the
ability to just just send just a portion
of the resource and specify what you
want update delete of course allows us
to and delete and a resource and then we
have some others options that allow us
to that allows us to basically query
query and endpoint and just say well
what methods are available get post put
delete and so on it'll return that
information head is really just kind of
a thing and then trace a trace is
another one that's very rarely used just
can be used for debugging but it also
opens up some vulnerabilities so it's
actually not really recommended to use
that what about idempotence what's
idempotence and what it why is it
important and rest idempotence you can
execute an action as many times as you
want and it will always have it'll have
the same effect on the resource so
there's many times as I do an update if
I if I execute the same update statement
it will it will always result in the
same in the same result so because of
that rest rest
services just define what you know what
actions are item potent and which ones
aren't so get of course oh yeah get
decide important because we're not sorry
the result might be different is
somebody deleted it but but the actual
the the fact that I'm doing it get I
shouldn't be affecting any server-side
resources so that is idempotent post
it's not idempotent because if I do an
insert multiple times I'm adding a new
record I'm creating a new resource over
and over so it's not I don't put input
it is it's an update delete is
idempotent because once i've deleted if
i go to delete it again it's it's not
going to delete another record it'll
just not find the record and not delete
it and patch like put is also idempotent
asp.net core web api if you build a web
api with a Spadina core that does not
mean it's restful service it's just a
framework and it supports rest it
supports all the verbs and as I
mentioned I would say many and probably
most for sure most web services that
I've seen are not rest restful and
that's largely because we treat them
like they're WCF services we treat them
more like a business layer than we do as
a data layer or repository rest is
really its besides being an
architectural standard and there's some
things in place it's really a mindset
and we have to change the way that we
think about dealing with our resources
and it does require adoption or buy-in
by both client and server-side teams in
order to make that happen now obviously
if the server-side team controls the
restful service the client has to buy
into it but in a case I also want to say
that rest is not the answer to all of
your problems there are definitely some
challenges to the that to be solved and
and and that's why they're still WCF
services and why they're graphic UIL
that came about what about swagger
well swagger it just is a tool really
it's a documentation tool very similar
if you ever built soap services or WCF
services
approach familiar with with the the
client generator or wisdoms so the XML
documentation for the service and then
you could go and and generate a client
actually a wrapper for your for your XML
web service or for your WCF service
swagger gives us some of those same
capabilities in some ways it's actually
cooler because with swagger we can go in
and we can actually test the services
right there I know we could do that with
soap as well but it seems like this is a
little bit a little bit more flexible
we'll take a look at that and just a
moment okay
let's take a look at swagger real quick
with swagger with a with the resources
that we've mentioned there we've got
excuse me with categories I've got get
and you can see with a with this get
with swagger I can open that up and
there's a try it out button and with
execute of course it allows us to then
execute our command and we can see so we
can test our service right here we can
we can test the individual endpoints in
addition to that notice that it shows
and it's color-coded that's so that's a
bonus I guess so you can specify which
end point or which verb it is that were
that we're testing I get post here have
what we'll get into why I have three
different gets underneath expenses in in
just a moment but let's take a look at
building our service
you know we'll get into looking at
postman as well I am in the wrong idea
okay normally I would definitely not do
this project in the in a single project
I have I'd have at least three projects
that have data transfer objects or DTO
library that has my data objects and
interfaces I'd have a data repository
but the for the sake of simplicity I
have my models and my data layer right
here i am using entity framework or for
this so if we just look at the did he
details briefly then we can build from
around there so my user class just like
the database table has a user ID first
name and last name category
whoops expenses will start there I
changed my mind as I was developing this
the database tables budget item and had
budget item ID here I wanted to call it
expenses so we have all the same
properties of their expense ID user ID
day time and so on and then category
there very simple poco objects right for
my entity framework we simply created a
database context and really if you're
not familiar with entity framework I
don't want to get caught up in entity
framework really I want to get to the
meat which is just talking about dealing
with the resources in restful way so but
here with ng framework this allows me to
manage the really the objects so so I've
got a database set or DB set of users
they're basically just my rows my users
expenses and categories rows that we can
work with so there are a few first of
all if I were to add a new project from
in in Visual Studio
it will run as Microsoft always does
they'll give you a demo controller that
allows you to you know has the restful
endpoints values with some strings but
it'll run automatically it doesn't have
swagger installed and really there's no
need to have swagger if you understand
the service if you understand it
endpoints then then you don't have to
have swagger swagger is really just the
documentation but to get things going if
I since I do want to have swagger
there's a couple of things that we need
to do to set up our project and that is
in our in our service API there's a
start-up CS and in our startup we have
this configuration so that that's what
application is going to start I need to
setup configuration services by default
the services dot ad MVC is going to be
set up for you already
API versioning that was not set up
sorry that's that's one that we had to
add in there so if you want to if you an
enable versioning of your of your
restful services then then you need to
we need to actually add that in as well
that's a change in dotnet core 2.2 used
to be added right into the core
framework but but now you need to you
need to add a new get package for that
and add the reference in here the excuse
me for swagger configuration one of the
configurations we had here is so I added
just a cookie policy so checking for
cookies just the de comment from the
same site I added a configuration option
actually I don't need this anymore
because I changed the way I changed the
way that I was doing that I was handling
this inside of here so so I don't need
the kit the configuration here that was
because I was going to read the
connection string from from a
configuration file course cross-site
scripting will be important now that's
mainly if we're going to be using our
service if we want to expose it to to an
angular or react client or view J's
client or something like that so you
need to have
your core you need to add cores and in
addition to that you'll see that and
adding cores and come down one second
there's configure services and there's
another section that is just the
configure section where with our cores
options so after we've added cores with
use cores we need to specify where we're
gonna allow that here I've just opened
it up so we could allow a request from
from any client from any from any orange
and and any method you could really
limit that to at this point that you're
only going to allow get post put just
which which items you want and which
which origin or what URL basically what
clients you want to you want to allow
that for the so in talking about
security of obviously those are some
things you want to consider and and make
sure that you you only allow requests
from the right place but there's more
than that obviously excuse me the other
thing that swagger requires is we need
to when we say app dot use swagger and
then we need to specify where our
swagger definition is going to come from
so let me run this one more time and
just show you what we're getting from
our swagger definition and really what
is swagger so well here we can see a
swagger a screen that helps us kind of
test that but but there's a link right
here that swagger v1 swagger JSON so if
I look at that that was defined right
here in my swagger UI where I'm gonna
pull that information from so I have a
name of the the swagger client and then
also where the JSON or the definition is
created really swagger for using swagger
it's just a definition document it can
be done in Y Amal or JSON and then we
could we could distribute that very much
like we like we distributed wisdom
documents and then clients could be
generated from from that
excuse me so if I look at this
swagger JSON you can see that it really
is just a JSON file I'm not gonna go
through and describe what all this says
for us just know that describes what
methods are available what data types
are are in there and from that this this
UI is actually this test UI is actually
develop as well so we can see that there
are three endpoints that were created
the categories endpoint the expenses
endpoint and the users endpoint
additionally it will also show you what
models are available and if we're strict
to adhering to what rest does the models
should very closely should closely
resemble how many endpoints we have that
we're working with because we don't want
multiple different models coming working
within within a single endpoint so our
category model just defines it this
looks like our our tables and our our
DTO so that we that we looked at earlier
okay let's look at building the
controller's once who built our models
we can build our controller and as
you've probably experienced as well if I
go to my controllers and I choose add
controller because I'm using env
framework I can choose to create a
controller with actions using ng
framework right from here if if my entry
framework is outside of this if I really
have a repository posit or e layer where
I'm going to manage that connection I
wouldn't do this I'd manage these
directly but for the sake of
demonstration we can we can definitely
see what we can do with that and so I'm
going to choose add I'll just go with a
simple model right here for miss in my
model I'll just go with a user actually
user and category about the same and I'm
just using my budget context because I
already have a users this is just going
to create users two users one controller
will go ahead and hit add
and it only creates the the four methods
or the four HTTP verbs that I talked
about earlier it doesn't even create a
patch for us so we can see that it
creates just because I'm using an ER
framework it creates a budget context so
my database context inside of here and
it will actually build all of my logic
for me whoo-hoo I generally like to have
a little bit more control over that but
with our restful services we have HTTP
GET and then we also see based on our
based on our URL we can also see with
the path that we can see we have an HTTP
GET with ID and so in this case the
example is that the ID would also be
would would be part of the URL so not in
a query string so those are two types of
query strings that we can control and
there's going to be some reasons why we
want to to limit them in different ways
we may have a we may have a path
parameter or may have query string
parameters so we'll build we'll look at
that just momentarily they get both the
the get notice this is a list or an
ienumerable of users and they get by ID
returns just a single user and that's
why I said we usually will have to gets
most of the time you're probably going
to have more than that if you want to
allow the users to control to filter a
little bit more you'll you'll definitely
have more guests than that but what you
don't want to do is you don't want to
get out of control and start having
having them not well I guess passing and
multiple query parameters is fine but
but you don't want to change what it is
that you're returning with each of the
different types of gets or put notice it
with put and post actually with the post
all we have is we're inserting a new
user so the only thing is we're passing
in the user with a put this was
something that was a kind of new to me
when when I first started coming to
interesting services I'm passing in both
the the object that I'm updating as well
as
the idea of the object so the primary
key this concept I mean really in the
development that I'd done before that
was it was kind of foreign because the
user already has that idea I'm updating
user I should already know what the idea
is inside of there but but but that's a
standard or that's a that's kind of a
standard practice to pass an ID for
whatever reason just to guarantee this
is the ID that we have in here notice
that with the logic that Microsoft puts
in they actually check to see if the ID
that we passed in matches the user ID
and if it doesn't and they'll do it
they'll return a bad request and this is
just a kind of demo demo logic the that
these are these web services were put in
for us the scaffolding put in for us and
then post like I said just as an insert
if we look at the logic it does insert
and then returns a created at action so
it actually will will return where it
came from so we can recall that action
if we want which is a get user so in
other words we can pass in to get user
with the ID so we can we can return the
actual object that was inserted so we
get the new idea ID from there as well
same things delete user we don't need to
pass in anything but the ID we're just
deleting an object so why pass in more
data than we need to and just to help
our method inside of there the other
thing that we're going to look at that
we want to consider as we go through as
we as we build our services here
I had several thoughts that went through
my mind and I forgot the one that I
started it'll come back to me so but
really one of the things that we
definitely wanna consider is how are we
going to use the data obviously and how
many records you were dealing with now
for a very simple application this may
be all we need
but as we as our application grows we
may have millions of records that we're
working with and and returning all
millions of our records
it just doesn't make this doesn't make a
lot of sense so let's look at let's dig
into the front-end application and see
how how we're using that actually I did
want to look at postman first I know
that I if we look at postman right here
I don't know if any of you guys I
recently found is insomnia I don't know
if any of you guys have seen that before
it's basically like postman but I
actually like it better it just seems
like it's a little bit easier to use
does the same things for us where I can
go in with insomnia I can pass in the
URL of the the object they don't want to
get and and I can specify if I want to
do a get post put patch delete or any of
the verbs that we talked about so I can
test each of these manually from here so
if I'm testing my users let's just go
with that for right now I can't test it
unless it's running I'm gonna come back
to and delete that second controller
that I just added
no it didn't I had that in there before
yeah so in fact even without swagger I
could I would be able to use insomnia or
postman directly from there and and like
I said swagger is really more of a it's
kind of a documentation tool it allows
us to have some manual testing but it
also allows the clients then to know
what the contracts are so we're building
contracts around that and that's why
we're versioning comes into play as well
this isn't what necessarily what I had
in mind before but one of the thoughts
that I had was with with versioning you
also want to be careful how you version
your your your endpoints and your API is
one of the one of the places that I
worked were had really more of a WCF
style web api
you know we cut we call them restful
services there were anything about
restful services they they did exactly
all the things that I just mentioned are
in there so we had one method that was
called get customer and and we we
returned a customer object in a certain
way it had all the data about the
customer and there was all kinds of data
within there and then and then one of
the our Android team I think it was they
said well we want to have a get customer
but but we we only want this data and so
so the the client was dictating what the
API team was what was supposed to be
returning and so what we what we ended
up doing was we created a another and
another get in fact another get customer
who called it version 2 and it took a
different input and it returned ad
structure was completely different from
from the previous one so we had version
1 for iOS and version 2 for Android and
then and then they were talking about
creating a third version because they
were wanting to move away from that that
you know that that goes against the
whole concept of why we've been moving
to into this restful services the idea
is that we define what a resource looks
like and then and then we have this
repository it controls how we get access
to that and the client manages what it
does with that data so excuse me
ok so it's running now I've got insomnia
running here I just have my localhost
users if I hit send it will return my
list of users because of the users the
way that it's set up if I pass in a
parameter of user ID to when I hit send
it it should only return that one that
one user I'm gonna go ahead and in my
swagger service one of the nice things
here too is if I'm going to go to users
if I do a post notice here's an example
so it has the JSON for me on what what
the example should look like let me come
into this users and I'm gonna add a post
inside of here with a post I don't want
to put it too because that would that
would fail because it wouldn't find that
resource that
doesn't exist but here I can help
where's come on body type oh there we go
JSON so user ID since I'm passing in
user ID posting that in I'm not gonna
pass that in that'll be created for me
automatically we'll just go with Gregor
and sorry I can't zoom in here in
postman or in insomnia otherwise already
use postman there for that so but since
I've chosen to post I need to pass in
the body of the text in this case all I
need is the first name in the last name
will hit Send and it returns that object
for me and notice that is because when I
hit post where's my user with the post
method
what do I have here all that's put sorry
I can't read because of this create
action method at the end it returns an
action result user so so it'll actually
go and and reuse that get user method
and and return that created action for
me and return the user object I can
verify that user actually exists now by
going back to get and I'll choose send
and we'll see six users and I'm there at
the bottom as well
what about we'll go with expenses and I
know it's capitalized inside of there
just because that's how my controller is
but it doesn't need to be capitalized
with my expenses I've got several
expenses a not not a whole lot of
expenses but you can imagine as as this
app gets used there'll be hundreds or
thousands of of line items inside of
here so we want to be able to with our
expenses I want to be able to dictate
how I'm going to pass that so with my
expenses and this is one of the places
where I might have more than one get
inside of there what I want to manage
let's open up the expenses controller I
have a HTTP GET and there's an HTTP GET
by ID actually inserted this in in the
wrong place let me stop this real quick
and I'll show you what happens with
swagger when I try to create this in a
certain way so
okay by default I have my get I have the
get all and is just gonna return all all
expenses
I found returned individual one I pass
an ID and because I've had I've passed
this oh I guess that's one thing when I
mentioned the route is an important part
of these web api's with asp.net MVC and
web api pre connect or we we could
control the routes what we still can
but a common way to control them was
that we had a in our startup we called a
a route config file and we can have
multiple different types of
configurations they were all in one
central place as Microsoft has gone
through and as developers have kind of
worked with this I realize you know it's
much better to control which route I'm
listening to right at the controller I'd
rather have I'd rather be able to
dictate that for this method right here
that I want to I want to specify what
what path I want to listen for what
route I'm actually looking for so for
the class by default you'll see up at
the top for Web API is it'll put API and
then in square brackets controller so it
just defaults to whatever the controller
name is you could specify the controller
here to hard-code that but by having
them in square brackets it dynamically
determined it is based on the controller
name here expenses in this case and
that's why the the Web API or swagger
used the capital e for for expenses if I
if I want to change that I can just
change the lowercase expenses right here
and that means that every method within
this controller will will have that as
the base route but it's let us listen to
so the only thing that I need to define
and here is anything that deviates from
that for example HTTP GET I'm not
passing in any parameter so I don't need
to specify anything with that and it
will it will know to come here with this
get by ID this will be appended the ID
in curly braces will be appended at the
end of will at the end of the expenses
route using the get verb and then and
then comes a question what if I want to
add my own query string parameters I
want to be able to pass in I want to get
expensive by page so I don't have a
logic I wanna say okay I want page
number five and here's the size of page
that I want so I can add logic to be
able to to deal with that paging if I
try to remove that page from there this
now becomes ambiguous swagger or the
routing engine it won't really know how
to deal with with the configuration here
so let me run this and you'll see that
swagger is not happy this is something
that that can be really frustrating at
times when you when you come through
this as you're building things you know
you've built it right then you come in
you open up swagger in it and it's not
happy what I found usually when I do
this is I'll go and I'll comment out all
the methods and one by one we add them
back in and see which one which one
caused the problem and that's because I
really I need to specify a route that is
a little bit more unique now I could
have called this get expenses by page
like it says here and and we could we
could definitely have that up there so
it can be another end point I prefer to
just I already know that I'm working
with expenses and I prefer just to give
it an end point or a URL name called
page in this case and whatever I pass in
a query string a speed on that nBC will
and that's that with MVC engine that's
been around for a while it'll actually
map those items to us so as long as the
parameter the query parameters page
there named page and size it will map
those to those those parameters now I've
made them integers if they're not
integers that's gonna that's gonna fail
on me here but but it does that mapping
for us I hate saying it this way but but
it's fast and it's true it's NBC magic
happens right
it's not magic it's a it's just mapped
so but we've got the magic that's that's
in there that maps that to there and
then I can then I can pull that out
excuse me
let's look at real briefly on the client
I don't want to get too I don't want to
get deep into angular at all but what I
do want to show you is just the three
services that I'm actually using that
call that call the the API so I've built
in the expenses there is an expense
service
I didn't flesh all of them out
I can't sue min here either
well with the expense service with a you
know what I will just take this put it
in okay so inside the service basically
I just create a variable expense URL
which is my base URL for expenses the
HTTP client for for angular happens to
be just I all have to say is return HTTP
GET I am specifying the return type so
I've just got a generic there and I need
to pass in my URL unless I wanted I want
to pass some additional information
within the header there's nothing else
that I need to do inside of there so
react use and yes if use Axios or view
whatever using their they've all got
wrappers around this that make this very
simple to be able to do that as long as
you have your URL and you know what the
data type is it needs to go in you can
pass that in for for the if I want to
get so that's this is all expenses where
I just get expenses this expenses URL
for this top one I've just added in the
page ID in the size and then and then
I've only done an ad expense inside of
here so I didn't deal with the update or
anything but notice that this is a post
so for the post I just determined I I
didn't need to worry about the data so I
just called it as a void so I'm not
waiting for any any date of this back
has passed in the expense URL and then
my object it's just a JSON object that
the web api will will pick up on the
other end and insert we've got just a
minute there's one one other thought
that I wanted to look at here and that
is I wanted to compare one of the issues
that you know one of the downsides of
using rests actually and that is in the
expense component in the expense
component when I want to display my
expenses here I want to display the user
name the category and the amount so the
users information is not part of the
expense all I have inside of there is
user ID either category D and so on that
means I need to go into the database I
need to go and make a call or at least
three different calls one to get all the
the budget items one to get the users
and one to get the categories there's a
couple of ways of dealing with this I
just want to show you some of the
potential issues you might run into by
dealing with this so one option is I
could call get expenses and then as I go
through my get expenses what I do is
first I go and get all the expenses and
then when I when I get them back I can
do for each loop through every expense
and call the get user and get category
service for that individual user we call
get expenses here when we save that and
you're going to notice you're going to
notice a huge difference immediately
maybe one that shows that it doesn't
even work
response here
well let me just describe it since we're
out of time what's happening is for all
the users and I've even trimmed it down
to where I only have five expenses on a
page I make a call and in that scenario
I'm making a call to two calls for each
row each expense so one to get the five
expenses plus ten more to my web api
just to get the users a way to get
around that obviously we could deal with
we you could add some caching on the
client side to be able to avoid that
round-trip the the way that I got around
it here is I first called and made sure
that I owed 'add just a collection of
users in a collection of categories
first so so I called get users and when
I got the users I then called get
categories and then once I called get
categories then I called get expenses
and then instead of looping through and
instead of looping through and calling
my web api for each user I just I just
went into defined against that and even
there that may not be the best option
something that we did fairly quick quick
inside of here but but those are some of
the things that you want to be concerned
with when you're building restful
services and if you're going to build
the restful services the way they were
intended the each endpoint should focus
on one structure and that or a one we on
one resource only and not the
relationships to other resources but the
real world is you're not going to build
a page that only has that only accesses
data from that one resource you need to
get access to the related data so so the
client it really puts the burden on the
client to determine how am I going to
get that other data and if I have an
object that has just has users first
name and last name but then I go to
expenses and it might have in a database
it might have 50 columns or what however
many columns and not only need two of
them when I make the call to the get
expenses records I may be loading a lot
more data than I then I need so those
are decisions that really go all those
things or decisions that go into using
restful services
and and how do i mitigate that you know
what kind of caching am I going to put
in place not just on the server side but
even on the client side so I guess in
the end with with rest you know if we go
if we go that direction with rest there
it's well defined and it makes it very
easy to build the server side makes it
easy to to to separate the client from
from the server and you can you can
really expose your service to many more
clients and have a standard for
everybody to follow but but again
there's some other considerations too to
deal with and and I would go ahead and
say that you know rest isn't the answer
for all isn't the solution for all
problems thank you
I should have no positive note it is a
solution for many problems
[Laughter]